you guys have been on the road for a
while what was your trip like here to
Toronto
it was early was it crazy things that
happen when you're on the road [ __ ]
always have to stop a border control it
like okay the key is to keep your eyes
closed
but this time I like I walked and I sat
down and I closed my eyes and then when
they call it their name way I went right
back to my best and I went way to sleep
it was it was actually the easiest one
I've had ever but you know what you guys
aren't really on a massive tour I was
trying to get parking here and I could
not get parking huge fans for you
they're just going crazy like it's not
just the kids it's the parents that are
here as well I mean what do your fans
mean to you when you see that kind of
love and energy
I mean it's unreal every single show is
just moved us so much because it's our
biggest tour ever we can't believe this
many people would come out to our
headlining show and they're and they're
like our moms with their daughters with
their daughters and it's cool that we
can bring families together and like
have such a special night night after
night yeah and when you're on the road
there's some positives not so positive
yeah so what are your positives and not
so positive mainly positives this joy
yeah yeah I mean it's because these
venues are so big and like because we
get a lot of like perks and we all get
our own dressing room it's also really
lovely to create a schedule like now
because of Taurus a big we have like a
personal trainer and and hey and like
the catering is really delicious and
really healthy and so you can kind of
create like how you want your day to go
and how to break down like sometimes we
have a masseuse come on if you know
you're not feeling well I'm for the crew
as well so it's really great it's nice
that everyone kind of has their own job
because everything is done very
efficiently and it it makes all the cons
not feel as kind like
not be with your family and this is your
but another Pro is like getting to
travel I feel I can sing friends that
you wouldn't normally see because you
would be in one spot the entire time for
a job anyway you and I mean that's
always really lovely I think and because
the tour's been so long we've traveled
like actually all over and seen so many
different people so that's been really
lovely there were spots it's one of my
favorite spot where else we always love
going to New York
Dallas was amazing I said yeah cuz
that's where we're from and so just the
hometown crowd is always really amazing
I sort of surprised when Charlotte was
like really wowed energy there was like
unreal yeah what does it mean when you
you're singing out there to your fans
and their fans are singing back at you
right there so the colors yeah yeah so
sorry only thing I love when they know
the arrangements to like we have every
autumn medley of this tour and for a
while we had it and put it on YouTube
yet so you could tell fans were like we
love these songs we don't know what's
coming next
know when they're singing along and it's
just so cool it's cool so when you sing
these songs these covers does one person
decide which cover you want to do or is
it a mutual decision together definitely
mutual decisions so usually it's one or
two people bring it to the group and say
hey we really like the song and we think
we would do a good job
do you connect with the artists who
actually made the original song
sometimes sometime yeah sometimes has
anyone ever contacts you back an artist
after you've done your type of their
cover yeah there's a few times that's
happened I think the most recent was
Camilla like my dad loved all right yeah
did you respond back is there something
you wish you didn't do oh that we've
already covered no we're in red covering
probably haven't put up on YouTube so
for example we tried I think I knew
what's on you - no no we tried but we
decided no it was a long time ago yeah
there's also madness madness madness and
then we try the Justin Bieber when that
in videos but the thing is the last like
four years everything that we have a
ranch we've yeah yeah this show it's
because it should go to sleep we have so
many new songs to do now Elias yeah in
the way and it seems like your your tour
is really focused on your PTX presents
pop Volume one yeah
and why is that do you want to not bring
in at the older stuff that you've done I
feel like I'm talking a lot and I it's a
little bit like if I well if I were in
the audience and they did and pentatonix
did like a song for 2014 I'd be like oh
that's cool nobody here is really that
excited about it and it's also really
cold so like why are they doing it kind
of thing but I also have you tested it
out that matter I feel like well your
songs that are like you know even from
what is our oldest one that we've had
like honestly we've been talking and
we've done a song for the last seven
years except for this year specifically
only because we had to just kind of like
rearrange and fix our set and like focus
it but at with you holes never than new
um but I mean Daft Punk is old and
what's another one like you know what I
mean like that's kind of like oh gee I
love you long time I was like a really
old throwback so we're bringing
different elements that don't feel like
you're we just don't want it to feel
like you're saying the same show every
single time so that's why we're bringing
some old ones in and then throwing the
new ones in there as well and we want to
keep ourselves inspired and
ever I feel like we get really excited
about regarding our music is what our
fans will get excited about so we just
like try to keep keep stuff fresh yeah
you guys are like a pop band I mean
you're up there dancing do your thing
it's pretty pretty awesome
that must be an important element for
you to be able to do that and actually
see you as a band so that you guys are
al capella but you really are a band up
there
yeah totally just using our voice yeah
and talking about your voices how to
take care of them yeah stress of keeping
your voice yeah about a hundred percent
can be overwhelming we're like 32 33
shows and now so just like and you'll
always hear about all these artists like
having have surgeries and they have
nodes and they have to go on vocal rest
well that's a thing for a reason it's
because they're using their voice so
much and we are definitely using our
voice a lot too well not only because
it's an acapella show but because we're
doing shows night after night oh and so
that's always a stress but this has been
a really good tour so would like in
towards before has anyone almost kind of
lost their voice great and getting
onstage was there a fear of that
happening yeah so what happens with that
that scenario happens you guys you
shorten the show shorten the show
certain songs we've had so Lois's we've
rearranged things right before the show
before do your best because it's on it's
obviously like really sad to go on stage
and feel like you can't perform
adequately or do your best but everyone
just tries to kind of cover and you just
have to put a big smile on because
honestly because it is five people and
because it's more about that you know
the overall thing like yeah you just
have to play for the overall team as
opposed to caring about what yourself
what you're what you are going through
information - they're super patient when
someone has like when their voice is at
80 percent of some things we're always
like saying
they're ready to sing a lot our fans are
yeah he does that a lot everybody else
will there be a volume do Oh
will there be a different trend to the
covers you will be doing I'm not sure
well I think the original plan was I'm
speaking for the band the original plan
is to do like songs of the year yeah
okay biggest songs of the year do you
get to work on other projects while
you're on the road yeah well you yes you
need a pentatonic stuff it's very
possible it's just hard that was it yeah
we have the time to guys I mean on off
days you can do whatever you want most
of the time we've been chilling oh yeah
we are working on a lot of stuff